je suis très heureux de vous recevoir
merci c'est vrai que tout à l'heure je
voulais dire à aloge et c'était pas du
tout que vous êtes très jeune on a pas
totalement on n'est pas tellement loin
mais c'est vrai que moi je regardais
beaucoup avec ma grand-mère je regarde
les spectacles et tout donc c'est très
touchant pour moi
il a traversé des génial c'est tout à
fait mais c'est un petit peu heureux
parce que la première déclaration que
j'ai lu beaucoup d'interview de vous et
vous dites la télé m'emmerde on m'invite
souvent j'ai jamais envie d'y aller donc
déjà merci beaucoup de venir aujourd'hui
franchement et donc qu'est-ce qui a
changé dans le fait que la télé vous
emmerde aujourd'hui pourquoi vous voulez
pas venir à la télé
souvent
voilà donc tu vois j'espère que tu as
coché non souvent puis moi je suis c'est
ce que je disais à notre camarade je
suis extrêmement nature je me pose pas
de question ouais ça m'emmerde je me
casse ça m'emmerde pas
d'accord je pense que le public qui nous
regarde aime bien les gens en vrai et
souvent la télévision avec la lumière
comme ça on a tendance un peu parfois
être différent de sa propre personne et
moi je c'est quelque chose que je refuse
je pense que le spectacle le sait
peut-être une entre nous il y a
peut-être une distance mais on est très
rapproché du public et le public le sent
tout de suite quand on est vrai ou faux
j'ai posé une question à Smaïn et qui
m'a dit pendant la pub la question me
l'a posé 10000 fois ça me casse déjà les
couilles et c'est barré voilà
[Applaudissements]
il est où l'acteur il est où lecteur
il y a un truc qui est génial c'est
quand tu l'as dit je suis sûr que les
gens chez eux le mec tu as vu
l'émotion qu'on passe en une seconde ou
alors ça veut dire que ou alors ça veut
dire que tu as été crédible en connard
mais je peux dire qu'avec la télé je
peux tout faire c'est très possible le
connard l'intelligent je peux tout faire
c'est très possible
tu as ta place par exemple
tu vas vite quand même parce que la
question qui va venir c'est la guerre je
regarde parce que je regarde souvent tes
PMP comme ça bon alors l'effet le fait
d'abord déjà le spectateur le plateau
est très petit
c'est vrai c'est vrai que quand on
regarde à la télévision on a
l'impression que le plateau pas du tout
c'est tout c'est minuscule c'est c'est
un peu comme mon appart quoi
c'est le petit lit qui font les grands
amants et donc c'est pas c'est pour ça
que je voulais voir cette sensation
voilà voilà normalement il y a Cyril qui
est là oh Cyril oh là là
dessous il y a qui Dieu ah voilà
t'embrasse ton Cyril
et alors attends là c'est la question
qui va t'agacer et après on passe à
autre chose la télé m'emmerde et là moi
qui vous connaît je vois l'artiste que
vous êtes vous jouez du Molière vous
faites du one man vous faites du cabaret
vous faites plein de choses et au moment
où on vous perd un petit peu la
télévision vous revenez dans ma Singer
qui pour moi pardon est une émission qui
j'irai pas humilie un peu mais c'est pas
bon pour les artistes mais pas du tout
pas du tout tu vois c'est ça qui est
incroyable pourquoi j'ai fait Maxime
d'argent mais pas bien payé oui certes
c'est pas que ça oui bien payé voilà on
va dire la vérité bien payé oui combien
j'ai fait pour ma fille
avec ma fille et l'émission passait et
elle était à côté de moi et je passe à
la télévision derrière le masque et tu
es pas dit rien
elle regarde comme ça il chante bien
elle Morgan c'est toi qui chante bien
elle savait immédiatement
alors après les gens alors c'est vrai
que ça vous a touché ou pas parce que
vous avez un jour un jour vous avez dit
j'en ai marre des des dealers d'opinions
qui disent ce qui est bien et pas et
vous avez dit dans une interview pardon
que ça à l'époque ça vous ça vous
brusquait beaucoup là ça vous a touché
ce qu'on dit sur Twitter tous les gens
qui sont ici ont fait le même métier on
est à l'image ouais quand on fait une
émission de télévision on vient en
danger tu sais pas la question qu'on va
te poser tu vois moi ça fait depuis très
longtemps que je vais ce métier là j'ai
fait comme un enfant tu vois et quand tu
fais une émission de télévision où il y
a je vais pas citer des gens qui te
posaient des questions c'est un peu
malfaisante un peu qui qui te qui te
dérange tu dis mais mais non mais moi je
l'ai fait comme un enfant pourquoi tu
m'agresses donc moi quand je n'aime pas
je parle pas à toi bien sûr je parle pas
c'est pas que je n'aime pas qu'on
m'agresse j'aime qu'on me pose des
questions intelligentes et j'essaie de
répondre aussi mais je trouve que ce qui
est dans dangereux dans ce métier là
c'est quand on te met parce que là je
suis face au public les gens m'écoutent
etc et les gens attendent c'est un peu
comme la reine ça marche ça marche pas
ça marche ça marche pas et et on a envie
de te déstabiliser moi je suis pas là
pour ça je suis là pour déconner
retrouver des portes voilà j'ai envie de
passer une heure et vous quand je dis
déjà
que il a fait plein de choses
petite anecdote mais il avait aussi un
resto un moment donné le 404 404 dans
Paris et moi petit congétais et fan de
smaïne qu'est-ce que je faisais j'allais
bouffer au 404 bon sang en fait que mon
idole j'irai la voir que semaine elle
est passée avec un couscous tu vois
salut je te sers tu vois et j'ai jamais
vu eh pas du tout
pourquoi les restos pourquoi parce que
c'était excitant de partir sans payer ah
oui c'était d'accord j'allais bouffer
dans mon resto et après je partais dans
un dans ton cul
[Applaudissements]
j'ai passé une heure et demie ou tu mets
comme un tes qualités au devant voilà
c'est vrai tenter de faire et dans une
interview sur une télévision algérienne
ça veut dire si j'ai bossé quand même
vous vous dites un moment le comics
c'est le miroir immédiat de la société
immédiate vous dites moi je suis un
comique des années 80 j'ai répondu à un
moment au problème des années 80 mais et
vous dites après tu arrives jamais le
gars des dossiers ça veut dire que
aujourd'hui vous seriez un comique dire
vous pourriez plus être répondre aux
problèmes d'aujourd'hui et ben c'est une
très bonne question
on ne peut pas être et avoir été
d'accord là il y a un moment moi
aujourd'hui je fais autre chose alors
quand j'entends les gens du smiley etc
et ben ils ont raison non mais oui ils
ont raison parce que je suis passé à
autre chose c'est merveilleux je te dis
quand j'étais gosse je voulais faire ce
métier je l'ai fait il arrive un moment
où toute carrière pour tout le monde ici
ça monte ça descend c'est le seuil de
compétences si un moment tu touches le
vert ou tu passes à autre chose et un
moment on nous permet pas de nous
réinventer il y a une très belle phrase
de devo ce qui dit le succès est un
accident c'est beau ça c'est un accident
c'est un accident on est dans la lumière
mais demain vous le serez plus les
copains demain terminé mais oui mais ça
va pas leur empêcher de continuer à
écrire à faire de la radio et exister la
lumière c'est extrêmement dangereux la
lumière parce que le jour où ça s'éteint
ben soit on est soit on est dans la dans
le noir on peut plus avancer ou soit on
a toujours sa petite lampe électrique
dans la poche comme ça puis on l'allume
et puis on fait autre chose
il a eu sa série commissariat Bastille
où il jouait un commissaire
à chaque fois que tu le vois que tu
bouffes avec lui c'est quelqu'un qui ne
critique jamais les nouveaux qui
critiquent jamais les jeunes plein de
gens qui ont fait ce métier le chanteur
comédien sont un peu agacés par
l'imagination qui arrive mais non mais
c'est un mec qui a jamais balancé sur
les autres et puis le festival un
festival à Dinard pour juger les les pas
pour de vrai qui aujourd'hui dans cette
nouvelle jeune génération Jamel et puis
maintenant dans la nouvelle génération
qui dans les humoristes aujourd'hui
répondent justement à cette immédiateté
de la société c'est pas parce que un
humoriste me fait pas rire qui n'est pas
drôle d'accord parce que c'est problème
de génération c'est un problème
générationnel aujourd'hui il y en a qui
me font rire je peux vous citer bouder
me fait beaucoup rire aussi j'adore de
Benoît me fait beaucoup rire Artus me
fait beaucoup j'adore mais c'est pas
parce que ils me font rire que ils ont
eu droit pour les autres c'est c'est une
question de de de j'aime beaucoup Alban
Ivan ouais bien sûr parce que bah
pourquoi pourquoi j'aime bien Alban
ibanov parce que j'adore moi
arythmique et il y a aussi une chose qui
est hyper importante pour les comics il
y a pas de toucher les comics
c'est-à-dire avoir une présence vocale
c'est un signature vocale c'est hyper
important donc moi quand je regarde les
comics bon il y en a qui me font Paris
il y en a qui me font rire etc ça
n'empêche pas que je leur dis pas
d'arrêter il faut il faut continuer et
puis en même temps pardonne-moi d'aller
plus loin il y en a trop ah ça c'est
vrai ça c'est vrai ça c'est le problème
c'est quand il y en a trop quand ils
sont bons et ben on les voit pas ça
c'est vrai et c'est pas vrai c'est aussi
comme c'est comme c'est quand même
comment dire c'est social c'est que le
rire il y a il y a 40 ans le rire on
était quoi on était cinq mais alors ben
moi bonsoir Aujourd'hui il y en a plein
il y en a plein de petits clubs aussi
oui justement
la serrure parce que c'est vrai qu'à
l'époque va être très honnête dans les
années 80 voir je sais pas comment on
dit un maghrébin je sais pas comment
vous voulez qu'on dise oui un
franco-algérien
français d'origine algérien algérienne
voilà monter sur scène et cartonné comme
ça il faut être honnête c'était une
révolution à l'époque manuel Jamel
Comedy Club
maintenant on est habitué à voir des
gens marocains tout ça j'arrive
maintenant je me plante j'arrive parce
que j'arrive dans un contexte on est en
1980 DVD minorités Mitterrand la marge
des beurre
j'arrive j'arrive au bon moment j'arrive
au moment où on touche pas mon pote tu
vois j'arrive au bon moment c'est on
voit le premier genre humoriste
d'origine maghrébine il arrive grâce à
Bouvard et genre merci encore tu vois et
là on se dit bah les mecs ils
sont pas dans les films qu'aujourd'hui
je déteste le mot beurre je déteste le
mot arabe non le mot beurre était
essentiel à l'époque aujourd'hui il
n'est plus c'est ce que je dis le beurre
il a fondu dans la société aujourd'hui
il y a plus besoin
mais à l'époque
à l'époque il était essentiel d'être
quelque part toi moi j'avais besoin moi
comment te dire tu vois je suis très
bavard c'est à dire que moi je vais vous
faire marrer un jour je vais à mon père
mon père adoptif moi je viens de
Constantine connaissant l'histoire des
sous X voilà et je voulais faire je
voulais je voulais faire ce métier
pourquoi parce qu'un jour j'ai pointé
mon doigt dans la télé je dis papa c'est
ce que je veux faire j'ai dit à mon père
coûte celle-là je dis papa papa j'ai
envie d'être acteur c'est ce qu'il m'a
dit il me dit midi ça coûte cher un
tracteur du coup
[Rires]
j'ai envie d'être connu je veux briller
et il m'a dit va faire la vaisselle
en gros j'avais envie d'avoir ma place
mais mettez-vous à notre place la guerre
d'Algérie les immigrés alors j'ai une
question besoin d'être quelque part j'ai
une question très simple je termine on a
besoin d'être quelqu'un on avait besoin
d'être quelque part moi j'ai pointé mon
doigt vers la télévision et j'avais
besoin d'être dans la lumière voilà dans
la lumière et un moment tu l'es puis au
moment tu les pues mais tu te dis bah je
l'ai été c'est déjà pas mal alors j'ai
deux questions très importantes très
importantes la première c'est la fameuse
question de Zemmour je suis désolé mais
j'ai tellement entendu que je veux te
répondre vous passez votre temps à dire
et je sais d'ailleurs que quand vous
avez fait Nice People à l'époque vous
avez reversé 50% de votre cachet à une
association franco-algérienne j'ai pas
de bêtises absolument donc c'est très
important pour vous l'Algérie les
racines et la France c'est fait et la
fameuse question de Zemmour quand vous
regardez un match France - Algérie vous
êtes pour qui
je suis
algérien de naissance français de
reconnaissance
de foot
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la question je vais te répondre et pour
la rappeler et ben je vais être pour
celui qui est le meilleur pour le
meilleur c'est beau c'est beau c'est une
réponse que j'ai
un truc que j'aime beaucoup chez vous
vous êtes cash vous parlez de tous les
traversées de déserts les machins les
succès vous avez joué Molière
je peux pas faire 25 minutes mais vous
avez participé beaucoup beaucoup au
début des Restos du Coeur et vraiment
c'était très important la nuit vraiment
fallait Démarrer puis après vous avez
été honnête vous avez dit bah maintenant
si on n'est pas notre petit carnet
d'adresse de mal Robin on épluche j'ai
pas dit ça c'est fou vas-y sors-moi la
fiche alors là ce que tu dis est une
grosse connerie ah non oui je suis car
je me casse non non
[Applaudissements]
ce que tu dis alors là si je vous
retrouve la fiche retour moi la fiche je
vous retrouve la fiche c'est très bien
je reviens la semaine prochaine et vous
courez autour du spectacle nuit autant
de autour de du plateau
vas-y sors-moi la fiche sors-moi
l'affiche je n'ai jamais dit ça vous
avez dit quoi je n'ai jamais dit
Monsieur j'ai dit que les restos du cœur
avait retiré mon rond de serviette voilà
et que un jour on t'appelle plus et on
peut appeler mais c'est pas parce que
Muriel Robin ou pas on se connaît bien
avec Muriel j'ai aucun problème aucun
souci mais un jour du jour au lendemain
je pense que j'étais au début des Restos
du cœur bon et un moment pas faut taper
le cul qui je sais pas mais j'ai jamais
accusé qui compte ou Muriel Robin faut
donc je reviens la semaine prochaine
avec grand plaisir on verra lequel les
deux couru alors juste une dernière
question
je voulais rester sur le plateau d'après
hein
il y a Véronique Mounier il y a je sais
bien vous êtes bavard
mais vous êtes talentueux je suis nature
j'ai tout de série là je vois ma course
en train de monter là donc si on peut
rester un petit peu ça c'est bien les
vous êtes dehors mais vous
croyez vraiment que ça vous savez ce que
j'ai j'espère parce que là c'est
horrible mais pas du tout vous savez ce
que c'est mon téléphone il y a rien il y
a ma gueule
ah ouais bonhomme ça c'est de la muscu
ça encore ça sympa à Porto-Vecchio
tu sais que ça fait plaisir
vous savez que Jean-Michel maire fait ça
aussi maintenant tu es en train de me
gratter le cul
c'est bien mon téléphone
[Applaudissements]
alors quand même je précise que Smaïn
vient de terminer le tournage
ça va être compliqué
le tournage du film d'Alice en Arcadie
on va le retrouver aussi dans son
spectacle déconne finement qui est en
tournée dans toutes les petites salles
de province et même les bêtes ça de
province avant d'arriver à Paris je
serai là si je suis invité je ne paye
jamais vous serez le 17 février auront 8
9 mars à montaubanze Marseille Givet 31
mars et 1er avril à la gérance sont les
28 mai au Touquet